Hey,
what's going on?
It's built burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And Ah,
I'm checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
How's,
ah,
oh Jesus.
Who knows what to how anything is I,
um,
I flew today,
so I'm,
whenever I fly,
I'm a little bit scatterbrained,
you know,
I left 7:10 AM flight,
so I'd get up at like five 15,
you know,
the shows didn't end till like 1130 or whatever.
Couldn't get to sleep till like two.
So my goal I got to do is just make sure I don't miss the alarm clock,
get up,
get to the airport,
stumbled through security and then not miss when they,
you know,
board the flight,
which I did.
So I get there and that's it,
you know,
at myself,
a little parfait,
you know,
at that guy's fucking restaurant.
He's on the chew,
the guy with the shaved head,
I went to his place and uh,
whatever.
I just got the Granola with the,
uh,
with the yogurt and some blueberries or some,
something like that.
Vaguely remember.
So I get on the plane and all I want to do is just go to sleep.
All right.
So I'd go to go to sleep and all of a sudden his fucking guy,
we'd get up to cruising altitude and this guy,
you know,
stands up wide awake,
like I sorta got six foot four dad jeans,
you know any of these awful shoes,
the shoes that you'd wear with a suit and you could tell he didn't want to pack
like a pair of like leisure shoes.
So he just wore those with this fucking awful dad jeans.
And he is just talking loud as shit.
Like one aisle up,
like yeah,
I dunno where he walked up from,
but he was a couple rows back and he came up and just talking to guy,
gone
figure that we had to the hotel around 10 30.
That way you get the burying all set up and after that we can maybe
try to decide what we're going to do with the game plan is for after lunch,
you know?
Then I hear the other guy that goes,
I just as I can understand what he's saying and the guy's like,
oh ha ha.
And I just wanted to like fucking,
yeah,
God,
his fucking shoes with the two buckles on them.
Two buckles really?
Like how crazy are you feet that you got to strap him into that level so you
don't have to,
they have a mind of their own.
So he finally walks back.
He goes,
yeah,
I want wanted to fuck you when he left.
So I finally knocked off and um,
I'm like sleeping deeply and all of a sudden I just feel this pressure on my
left arm
and,
and I feel somebody shaking me and I wake up and it's the stewardess.
She's class both my arms.
Nope,
my arm was both her hands like she's going to tell us that,
you know,
she getting the crash position something and I just look up at her.
I can't hear what the fuck she say.
And then I realized that my headphones on so I just take the headphones off.
I was like,
what?
What,
what's,
what's the matter?
She goes,
does she want breakfast today?
I mean,
yeah,
some point now when I'm sleeping,
I didn't think they did that.
I thought you only time they did.
That was when,
you know,
if there was like an emergency,
like I'm sorry,
I know you're sleeping,
but you gotta bring your seat back up.
Cause God knows,
you know,
that's so fucking crucial to the level of injury you're going to have at 37,000
feet.
Right.
I know it's kind of hacky material,
but that's what you think.
Right.
She woke me up to see if I want a breakfast.
And I was just saying,
I hope I wasn't an asshole.
I was like,
no,
I got to get a hat that says I had a fucking parfait.
Just let this old man sleep.
So,
um,
I dunno,
I just,
and I couldn't get back to sleep.
So I started watching,
uh,
this season of the ultimate fighter and,
I don't,
I mean I know I've seen most of the seasons.
I forgot about this guy who was this guy.
Oh,
the fuck was his name.
I can't remember.
But he just,
he was like in line to win the thing and he got completely hammered,
kicked out the windows on a limo,
you know,
he just went crazy and uh,
he got kicked off the show and completely,
I guess blue is shot at being an in the UFC,
so,
but he didn't quit.
He just kept fighting.
He's had like 45 cents.
And so they've got this big build up,
sort of the redemption house this year where it's people that you know,
were in it before and maybe didn't win.
I think that that's what it was.
Like I said,
I was half asleep,
so I was watching his,
um,
I was watching his whole pre fight versus the French dude who,
uh,
you know,
was good with the kicks and shit and I'm watching this stuff and what's weird is
to cut into the guy,
you know,
who got kicked off the show and one of his ears is sticking out so much further
than the other one.
Like,
and what kills me is the early part of the training.
It isn't,
so something happened to them during training.
Like what,
what the fuck happens to those guys ears.
I understand like all like the uh,
the fluid in them and stuff.
But this thing was just like,
I mean I can't,
it was like Mickey mouse ear.
Yeah.
Like one of those
sticking out straight out.
Like it was signaling to make a left.
And the other one,
you know,
sticks out a little bit,
but not that far.
And they never addressed like what happened?
He said some cool one point.
He said,
yeah,
you know,
he goes,
I've been around the world.
I got the scars to prove it and I'm going to go in there and I'm just going to
beat this guy down.
And that's exactly what he did.
And I was one of the few times I was excited that the Mike the gate wasn't ready
when we landed.
That's always the big jerk off.
You know when you get in early to the airport,
congratulations.
We're in 15 minutes early.
Unfortunately I gate is not available.
Of course it isn't because they weren't anticipating as being there and then
there's no place to go.
You know,
they should have like a little fucking ice cream thing down at the end of the
runway.
You know,
you peel off onto a little taxiway,
you know,
we just gets a little fucking Sunday or some shit.
We just basically,
the guy said these going to,
they're going to bring us to a,
uh,
I believe he said desolate part of the airport.
I know lax well enough at this point.
What they did,
they just,
we just did a lap around the whole thing.
We landed on the,
uh,
what did I ever the fuck it is the south side of the fucking airport.
And we just landed cause that's a side United design,
which by the way,
I'd like to apologize to the guy who got dragged off that fucking flight.
The fact that I ever flew that airline again,
I already had my ticket and I wasn't even paying attention.
I felt like such a fucking,
you know,
to fellow American,
they dragged off and even,
you know what,
even if he wasn't from here,
cause I don't know where the fuck he was from.
I think they assume it's going to chain or some shit.
Just human being,
the human being,
you know.
Um,
I just felt dirty riding on that fucking airline.
Uh,
so that,
that's,
I think that's it with those guys,
you know,
and when somebody else does something worse than,
than we actually all realize that United was actually,
oh,
you know,
they were actually kind of reserve let me smashed his cheekbone off the side of
the,
I just can't believe they can make you get leave.
Like,
no,
I'm not leaving.
Is the president getting on board,
then I'm not leaving.
Plus nowadays the president has his own fucking plane
to just kill me.
It's like,
what about that guy?
What about his plans?
What about his business?
What about his loved ones?
What about all of that shit?
Just fucking dragging the guy off as he's screaming.
That was one of the,
I dunno,
that was just,
it was just really a,
yeah.
You know what kills me is,
you know,
God damn well the head people at United Airlines,
when they looked at that footage,
all they thought about was just damage control.
They didn't give a fuck about that guy.
I Dunno.
Am I out of my mind?
That should not have happened in a first world country.
That was just like some,
uh,
overthrow the government.
There's no rules anymore.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
they just fucking manhandled that guy.
Like he did something.
You know what he did?
He paid for a seat.
That's what he did.
And he got on and he put his stuff in the overhead compartment.
He sat down like he was supposed to.
Then he got his fucking ass kicked or he got roughed up.
That'd be more than unites two minutes for roughing.
That's what you would get,
you know.
So,
um,
anyway,
so I get back to the fucking lax,
I'm still a little groggy or whatever.
And uh,
I always take taxis,
you know,
cause nobody takes taxes out here,
so they're always available.
You just walk right out.
And the guys there and a,
I got a pet peeve on my luggage,
right?
Like whenever you walk up with the luggage,
you know,
if the driver goes to take it,
what they do is they push the button to make the handle go down about three
quarters of the way and then then they just release it and then they,
and they just slammed the thing down.
So I always go,
just wait a second,
wait a second,
I'm let me just do it.
And the guy just kept grabbing for it.
I said,
wait a second,
guys looking at me,
go thinking I'm the Dick.
It's like I'm not a dick.
All right.
So once you fucking mess up the handling,
once you mess up the fucking handle,
now what am I going to do?
Carry it like it's the 1970s.
I travel like a stores.
So we get the whole thing down.
He gets in the car,
goes,
how was your flight?
I say it was great.
And he goes,
where are you going to tell him the address?
okay,
can you,
can you fucking type it into my phone?
Okay.
I Dunno.
Am I an asshole?
It's odd.
Now.
I don't know why.
I want you to fucking,
you can fucking do you want to way to,
once you slide over,
I'll fucking drive.
I know how to get home.
Um,
all right.
Jesus Christ.
This is why I don't do the podcast.
One of when I flew that day,
um,
as I mentioned that,
cause I'm like extra crabby and I had a great time,
by the way.
I'm in Cleveland,
Ohio.
Uh,
every time I come back there,
the downtown areas more alive.
I remember working at hit,
uh,
hilarides for the first time in 2004 was again in 2003 I was doing new year's
first time at Jason Lyon and a bunch of Cleveland guys and I just remember just
looking at the downtown area and there wasn't shit down there.
I mean I was staying at the Holiday Inn Express right around the corner and they
had to get me a fucking escort home.
I was literally walking a block and a half and I was thankful that they gave it
to me.
I did a fast paced walk over to the club before the show.
So I remember looking across the street and it was this big apartment building.
I remember just thinking like,
man,
if I had the fucking money
I would buy that and Redo it and I would be,
I would make a fortune on it and you know,
didn't have the money.
And now every time I go back there,
you should see it now.
Like,
like hilarity,
his was the only game in town there on this dark street.
Now you show up at literally life.
Like I said this before,
it looks like the fucking Bullwinkle show is a house of Blues.
There's this place called a,
I don't know,
some craft beer places.
All of this shit.
This gift shop t shirts store where they have all this stupid Cleveland stuff.
They look like Dave was soft t shirts.
I liked a lot of them and I actually like Ohio,
but like the nickname for Cleveland calling it the land is just,
it's so bad.
The Land Pittsburgh,
the Berg
is Cincinnati,
the natty.
It's so fucking terrific.
I thought Beantown was bad.
I always hated that growing up in Boston and the millennials started calling it
the bean.
So in Cleveland they have these fucking tee shirts.
It says defend the land from what you seceding from the union.
What are you talking about?
Uh,
I was happy for him.
You know,
they won their championship and all that type of shit,
you know,
and they're looking good.
Jesus Christ.
Absolutely fucking destroying the Toronto Raptors.
Yeah.
You know,
I was going to say,
I had a theory about the,
uh,
you know,
if you name your team after some fucking movie shit,
like the Anaheim mighty ducks,
the raptors,
we all know that's from Jurassic Park.
Like you never going to win a championship,
but goddamn ducks did.
But they had to stop being the mighty ducks.
I remember when they first came out,
there were the mighty ducks at the exact same uniforms as those little kids,
which is basically the bad news bears on ice.
And then they would up on the diamond vision,
they would have like Emilio Estevez clip from the movie of him given a Rah Rah
speech to a bunch of children.
And I'll tell you when they actually want a cup after that shit.
That really hurt me as a Bruins fan going like,
did we lose to a fucking team named after a kid movie?
I Dunno.
So anyways,
statement kicking the shit out of him.
And how about the Celtics Celtics continuing to fucking move through the
playoffs?
Up Two games to none against the west.
How about it?
He thought that was on death row.
Hold,
I can't believe it.
The Boston Celtics brand of basketball,
other than their refusal to quit,
I cannot fucking believe that we're winning.
We don't get any rebounds.
Was soft in the fucking paint.
We live and die by the three.
I mean,
that was that right there that you would say it was just the death of you.
And somehow,
you know,
I never going to run into that.
You know,
if we get by the wizards,
you never know what the fucking happened.
But when we run into that Cleveland Cavalier buzzsaw that that's just going to
be it.
It's going to be,
we're not going to have enough fucking answers.
Uh,
Kelly Olynyk trying to cover fucking
Hell Lebron James or Al Horford,
what's he gonna do?
He's not going to fucking,
you know.
Um,
anyways,
I,
I mentioned a couple podcasts ago that,
uh,
my wife had gone rogue when it came to the Dvr and all that and I promise that
she ever talked to her about it with you guys.
Um,
a mayday.
Your,
your request on the,
uh,
the podcast
you request,
you know,
your,
your presence is requested to is why I don't do pot.
I hate donut when I fly.
Um,
yeah.
You got a mic.
You got everything.
Here you go.
All right.
Now we're going to have to have a nice measured conversation.
Don't touch my luggage.
You don't have it like comfortable for guests right now.
Oh,
that's why I never have guests.
Hold on.
All right.
She's got to do the whole thing here.
Okay.
Oh,
who is this other person?
And she wasn't,
she wasn't booked.
What's up baby?
How are you?
Hi.
Let's,
let's get,
let's it to get her situated and she's fine.
She's,
she's changed.
Um,
anyways,
Nia.
Yes.
You've gone [inaudible] gone rogue.
First of all.
Welcome on the 10th anniversary.
Happy Anniversary.
Yeah,
that's 10 years.
10 years of a run in my year
and no idea where this was going to go.
And now look at me all these years later.
I remember sitting in my jeans and t shirt.
Yeah,
exactly like I was 10 years ago.
I have the exact same level of technology.
I don't have a theme song.
I haven't done anything.
Although you didn't have a soundboard and stuff before you just used to like,
oh yeah,
I usually call phone.
Yeah.
You used to call on the phone?
Yup.
How did that work you?
You called up some service?
I used to do it when I was on the phone.
I would drive around and I'd be getting the arguments with other people in the
cars and I would be at the airport and I just make fun of fun of people were
gay.
What gave you the idea to do a podcast?
I mean obviously it was became a big thing 10 years ago,
but was there somebody or something that happened that made you think like,
I need to get it on this?
You know,
I feel like I didn't choose podcasting.
Podcasting chose me.
Yeah,
no,
it was over a Bobby Kelly's apartment by Bobby's right.
I was over there and he was like,
dude,
you should do a podcast.
So we just set the thing up.
You know,
it was like Bobby Kelly,
shit,
Bobby into technology and I was like that.
It may be in the old crabby guy.
Even back then go do it.
I don't want to do that stuff.
Just you'll just say up to you to get away.
Connect with the fans bro.
He was Ryan.
Yes he was.
He was right.
He was right on that one.
You know what?
He was wrong about you or Bobby Kelly was wrong about the mini cds.
[inaudible] CDs.
Yeah.
When they was regular size cds,
he talked me into getting a mini CD.
Oh,
I,
yeah,
like that was going to take off and then I had to buy the microphone.
That was seven set up like a little tea.
I followed him for like two months.
I followed him down over the cliff of buying every piece of technology and then
I just went back to the fucking,
the way I was.
So anyways,
yes.
So know what's going on.
You know there's all these great shows out there that we used to watch together.
Well better call
Saul Fargo.
Meet me at the mall.
Good seasons.
All right.
All of these great shows.
Yeah,
and used to watch them with me and now all of a sudden,
not only do you not watch them with me,
you kind of erase them or decide,
you know,
it was some other show not to show.
As I just mentioned,
there was some other show we started to watch and you decided that you were over
it and you just,
you just stop recording it.
Okay.
Well you know probably because there's a way to watch it on like the Roku or on
demand.
Now for me,
I can't figure that out.
I have showed you that countless times.
I know.
Show you again,
but I'm not going to keep,
I like to say how many times I told you how to shut the water off when there's a
flood in the house.
There's certain things that were good at
okay.
Huh?
Oh,
you didn't like that.
Did you know my eye contact?
Really?
Nia.
Me.
What?
What didn't you like about that comment?
Oh,
this is getting real.
This is like fucking some Wendy Williams shit right now.
You stopped staring at me like you're going to beat the crap.
I hear to talk about the Dvr and the TV show stuff.
We were,
I think that is what I use.
Throwing that other evidence out that's made and told me,
is that what you're doing here?
I thought that was totally who to like flip the script is not,
that's not what I agreed to.
One 12 white people do not flip the script.
We have a misdirection.
We changed the subject.
I didn't,
I didn't agree to this.
I'm here to talk about um,
television and just like Billy Bob Thornton on that radio show and he said,
don't bring up my movie career.
Just talking about my drum career.
What's going on with you?
How do you know what you,
you change,
change,
change.
Well,
first of all,
one thing it hasn't changed is your inability to talk into a microphone.
Sorry,
love it.
Just pointed at the side of your face.
I'm just saying now that we've got the little one here.
Yes.
Well here's the thing.
Bell is that you're running around all day and so I'm here with her and so I
watch the shows then because it's like there's not really much to do,
you know,
I'm just kind of breastfeeding all day.
There's not a whole heck of a lot to do with her.
So I watch it and because you're busy and then at night when we do get time to
watch stuff,
you watch it for like 10 minutes and then you fall asleep.
Just cause I can never in the morning.
I understand that,
but I don't.
So then I don't get a chance to really learn enough.
Fair enough to get a do you got to erase it then you've got to make the
decisions on like what I get to watch.
No,
like,
well that's it for you.
And if you find,
if you turn on your Roku thing and download the news,
so simple like my mom does the Roku,
like it's that,
it's that easy.
So I was turning on and off a faucet outside the house.
All right,
well this has been fun.
Okay,
I'm leaving.
You're not leaving.
No one's ever walked off this show.
Who are you?
What are you doing right now?
You keep
belittling me of how easy it is you use Roku.
How has that political,
I said it's easy.
You're the one who doesn't have the power.
You said well now,
now you said what did I say?
You said even your mother can do it.
It's self to me a little bit.
Little bit.
You'd sell to me a little bit.
Why is my mother,
I'm just saying she's not the best at technology,
but
she knows how to use the no,
what you're saying it's as what I'm saying.
Alright.
You know,
I thought it was going to be a lot of comedy in this
woefully Ms Judge
how this was going to go.
No,
I know I went rogue.
I know I did,
but let's like,
yeah,
here we go.
Four minutes in.
All right.
Yeah,
I mean I just can't sit around waiting for you to like watch 10 I got tired of
watching episodes in 10 minute increments because you fall asleep and what am I
supposed to do?
I'm not yet.
I'm not tired yet,
so I want to finish watching the show.
I got to turn it off just because you fall asleep and it takes like six weeks to
get through two episodes.
That's insane.
I think you're exaggerating a little bit.
I am,
but the point is that I'm not going to wait for your ass to watch shows anymore.
It's just we're not on the same schedule,
so it's doesn't,
it's not really practical for us to like watch TV together like that.
Okay.
So that part of our relationship is,
I would definitely,
it's over.
All right.
Well here's the thing.
Yes.
Stop deciding,
you know,
being judged during execution on the death penalty for the shows that we record.
Uh Huh.
Okay.
And you know what's weird is,
you know,
I had all my self to games,
a Bruins games,
games are quarter summary.
I like three times.
I didn't finish the accusation.
I know three times this season I had to go back to get to start,
you know,
I had seasoned record,
I had three times I had to go back and do it.
And somehow that never seems to happen.
To your shows.
Only the my show.
So I can only surmise that the DVR doesn't like me.
I did not.
No,
I contact change.
I'll look right at you.
I didn't,
I didn't change the recording series for your sports stuff.
Mm.
Never been in the middle of recording two things that you like at the same time.
And this is all,
there's not enough space.
You need to stop recording on one thing.
And you never chose my stuff over your stuff.
No,
because it can record up to five things simultaneously.
All right.
You're recording five things and then there's one more.
Have you gone through the Dvr list?
Have you noted that like 98% of it is your stuff?
It's a complete lie.
You just paid it,
but yes,
I do want to bet.
I'll bet.
Yeah,
I'll bet you.
What do you want to bet?
I Dunno.
What should we bet?
Well,
you're the one who brought it up.
Um,
no,
I brought it the bed.
Sorry.
I'm of it,
you know,
I don't know.
It's just many gentleman's bet.
Okay.
Well,
you know,
if I was dealing with a gentleman,
oh,
I'm a gentle woman.
How about that?
I'm going to need the hospital.
You just lady race and my stuff.
I don't appreciate bill,
you have gushers thousands Patriot's games from Surrey from three years ago.
It's a Superbowl.
We want it,
but do you go back and watch it ever?
Why is it sitting there near?
That's one thing I know,
but it's like four hours.
It's a super bowl.
I know he'd beat the Seahawks.
Okay,
but are you going to go back and watch it if I actually,
okay,
but everything else is gone.
I all the fast and loud,
I get rid of those.
I've seen all of those.
I get rid of all my Bruins and Celtics and get rid of those.
There's a bunch of games as much as sports related documentaries and stuff that
you haven't watched because you don't have time to watch a lot of the TV,
which is fine,
but I'm just saying that's the reason why I have decided to just press forward.
Fair enough.
Full of the TV watching.
I wish you the best of luck.
If you cheat with your,
with your,
with your TV viewing.
No,
I enjoyed watching TV with you.
Oh and uh,
yeah,
it's just an end.
So,
okay,
well then let's figure out a solution.
Like how can we get back on track?
How can we get this right of our relationship back on track?
This is like there,
I don't know.
What can we do
in order to get on the same page?
Look,
if you're bored out of your mind during the day and you need to watch a good
show,
yeah,
by all means do it.
Whatever.
I just needed an explanation,
I guess.
That's all right.
I'll learn how I tell you what.
I'll learn how to use the Roku and you learn how to shut off the water the next
time.
One of these old as pipes burst.
What?
Why is it such a big deal,
nick?
Why do you keep bringing it up and you're trying to like humiliate me and
embarrass me?
I'm bringing it up because every time you talk to her like that,
I turn off the water.
I did and I called the plumber.
The makes him the very next day.
Yes,
I did.
So I'm tired of you making it seem like I don't know what the hell is going on.
Okay.
I was here by myself.
I was very well baby.
Yes.
I turn it off.
Turn it off.
Yeah,
I did.
And that crazy ass flooding that was going on.
So I cleaned up by myself.
[inaudible]
it's a little valve.
It's like it's blue.
It's the color of water.
Why cool.
Was that easy?
I could do it.
I forgot to do that part.
Okay.
I know.
And I called the plumber and they told me that it was fine and it was fine.
I know because we got lucky.
Yeah.
It's not like you made a judgment call gone.
You know it's coming from there.
I would take it out from the front of the house.
You didn't,
you didn't do it.
What I was going through.
You are starting your face.
You didn't do all you do whenever stuff like that happens when you're on the
road is giving me shit up.
No,
I will not give me shit about it over and over again instead of being like,
I understand you were alone,
you were panicked.
You don't handle the situations.
Thank God everything was okay.
Thank God you're okay.
Thank God the baby's okay.
Dam didn't break thing that I did wrong and how I didn't add the way you would
have acted.
You know what?
I think we learned here that I don't appreciate it.
Okay.
I
pay you guys listening.
You want me to flip out?
Yeah.
Poking me and poking me about it.
That was a month ago now.
Like let it go.
You've completely lost your composure.
Yeah.
Cause you're pissing me off.
All right.
You know what I learned in this conversation?
Nothing knowing you.
I have learned that I'm a little bit better handling criticism than you are.
No,
you are not.
Listen,
no,
you are the most sensitive jackass I've ever met in my end,
but I only took it.
Okay,
fair enough.
But I only took it to tit for tat.
You said Roco and so your petty too.
Okay.
So I'm petty,
but I mean,
I'm not the one yelling and flipping out here.
I am a passionate person and when I am feeling a certain way,
but the euphemisms though,
that's not a euphemism.
Yes,
it is a euphemism to this.
It's a nicer word for being a Douche.
Instead of saying instead saying,
listen to me.
Instead of saying yes,
I did.
Just like you know who um,
two rights don't make,
wait,
no two wrong.
All right.
You're right.
No,
it's like instead of saying shell shocked,
you say post traumatic stress disorder,
um,
set of saying innocent people died.
You say collateral damage.
That's a euphemism.
Oh,
all right.
Okay.
So there you go.
Instead of saying that you were an angry Lula tick,
you say you're passionate.
I'm not.
You're the angry lunatic.
I think we can all agree,
not me.
I am not.
I am the steady easy one.
Oh yeah.
Really?
Yeah.
Crazy one.
I don't know when I had to threaten to like,
if you hit me one more time during an argument,
I'm not going to go out with you anymore.
When I met you,
you were a grower and you were here.
Oh my God.
You just have,
you got to run for office.
She will answer for everything.
I was young and I was hashing it sure is young and immature and I didn't know
how to handle my emotions and I do now.
Okay.
All right.
What did you check yourself into?
Rehab.
Let's see.
Have a tech.
I punched him in the face.
I need to go to rehab or punched you in the face.
You did it.
Stop did it on Valentine's Day,
but she did.
Yes.
She did.
Not In the face and the face.
Yes.
Yes
you did.
I didn't punch you in the face.
I don't know.
I took you to that fancy Sushi restaurant.
We were living in New York.
I took you down to that thing and the dude,
the dude from the phone booth movie was there,
right?
Oh,
I'm in a phone booth.
They won't let me leave.
Right.
He's in that fucking thing.
That Nice low budget movie.
The whole movie takes place in a phone booth.
We love it.
Low budget,
Cute Irish guy.
Right.
Me As a ridiculous,
well,
you wouldn't
know that when you,
the way you were looking at him in the Sushi restaurant,
you just kept looking at the guy,
which was fine for the first,
you know,
10 minutes.
Then after awhile you just looking at another guy where I'm paying 10 times what
Sushi should cost were to sell.
Exaggerating.
What happened.
I wasn't staring at Collin for all the entire,
what are you going to validate my feelings?
Yeah.
I believe there was a song written about everything you've said on this podcast
back in the 80s.
It went something like this.
Yeah,
Dude.
The last lot that yeah,
to the bigger,
the better.
Lou.
That was the Thompson twins.
Uh,
how long had we been dating before that incident?
I don't know.
But what ended up happening was I got in the cab and I bought it with the cab
driver and I just said it got big buddy.
Let me ask you a question and stuck my big head to that stupid little window.
I got you.
Took you woman out on Valentine's state for Sushi.
All right.
Famous guy walks in.
How long do you give her to look at the famous guy before,
after a while and then public for that long.
Wow.
I never thought of it that way.
I don't mean farming out.
I don't know what,
I mean,
I was young.
I had to,
I had to get some sort of victory.
I was trying to marry the line.
No,
I was trying to make you as upset as you made me and it,
and I did it a little too well because by the end of the night we were back in
the apartment and you came running out of the bedroom because of course I'm
sleeping on the couch.
Of course I'm sleeping on the couch.
I wasn't looking at anybody else and I paid for the move for the meal.
Of course,
I ended up on the couch.
And uh,
you said something like that as some Bob bitching or something.
I said,
yeah,
well you're acting like one and I'd never called you that word now I'm sorry.
Here,
just two little feet.
Lord was not in the word in question.
That was not the word in question.
And you know it was a douchebag.
No,
it was not.
And you were saying,
why do you guys to speak into the microphone?
I got to act like such a,
you know what?
Yeah.
And I lost my shit.
No I didn't.
No,
I didn't.
This is what I said.
What did I say?
I didn't say.
I would never say no cause that's calling you one,
which I've never done.
Never did that.
Yeah,
you kind of did in there one time.
No,
I didn't.
You know you'd like to disguise it behind acting like a,
see this is a thing that I tell you something there.
Can I tell you like I tell you something,
you acting like I didn't say you were a,
you're acting like a fair enough.
But here's the thing.
I've been with you for 14 years.
You have two incidents despite your behavior.
How many times you know what for those two incidents,
how many times did you hit me?
I'm going to time you came in?
Yes.
Through my laundry.
All over the living room.
You haven't we freaking psycho.
I don't remember that.
Once your fluffy white socks and underwear like oh my God.
Ah,
another example of your passion.
I've shown unbelievable restraint dealing with a woman like you.
Oh,
a woman like me.
Yes.
All congratulate fucking lesions.
You got a beautiful baby out of it.
Yeah.
Is All right.
Oh,
we had a good time.
Yeah,
we had a nice run.
No,
it's all about her.
And evidently we're just going to be watching up separate stuff on TV.
No,
we can't be that couple.
We had to like,
you know,
still remain a tight,
I have to go see it.
Most Times I fall asleep at night because you're watching those,
those women yelling at each other.
I hate those shows now.
I know I why know that.
But we could be watching anything and you'll fall asleep cause you do,
you get up super early.
You're really busy throughout the day.
It makes sense.
So I get why you fall asleep,
but I'm just saying like it's hard to watch a TV show with you that way.
That's it.
Okay.
All right,
well listen,
it was nice talking to,
uh,
you know,
is that it?
Do I have to leave now?
Well,
I mean I got to read some advertising.
If you want to sit here and listen to that.
No,
Jesus.
I know deals.
Can you read out loud?
Don't let her listen to that either because that'll be hope.
She doesn't get that from me.
I get what your inability to read out loud.
You know what it is.
It's my brain goes too fast.
I find if I slow down when you read to her and so cute and so lovely.
Oh yeah,
you guys have all this.
I actually I rehearsed before the podcasts.
I read the advertising.
Okay.
Once upon a time there was a company named loot crate.
All right.
Be The envy of your friends and get 100% exclusive
crates@lukecrate.com slash burr and enter my code,
Burr B U R R to save $3 off any new subscription,
uh,
maze.
Luke crate theme is Guardians.
The best surprise,
you know,
is coming.
What
the best surprise you know,
is coming,
isn't it?
The best surprise is that you know it's coming or is this the best surprise you
know is coming.
I need to deliver this line.
You don't surprise,
you know is coming.
Yeah.
It really annoyed me.
How easily is you know is coming.
We'll be right back with more dancing with the stars.
Loot crate offers an epic range of pop culture items for less than $20 a month.
That's right.
If you're more of a fanatical fashionista than try loot where method man,
c'mon.
With that.
Monthly wearables and accessories with cult classics and your favorite
franchises in maize loot crate.
You'll find items from guardians of the Galaxy Two star wars destiny and the
Goonies.
Jesus are all over the map.
One minute you're in space.
Next scene or you got a bunch of dirty face kids coming at Ya.
One lucky subscriber will also,
when a mega crate including a premium format,
Groot figure,
g,
R,
O,
t,
whatever the hell is from sideshow,
collectibles,
guardians of the galaxy,
guardians of the galaxy group.
Okay.
That's what that character is.
It's from guardians of the galaxy.
Oh,
I thought that was like,
was it in killing and macaroon and novelist and actor,
actor,
him ice.
How do you say that word acronym?
An acronym?
Yeah.
No,
I don't.
I don't know.
Is that when it's like a mad mothers kids drinking and driving?
Is that an accurate backdoor him?
I can't say it
from,
sorry.
Well,
I know what it is.
She'll collectibles.
I honestly,
I'm not joking.
I can't say that word.
That is over 22.5 inches tall is why suck at wheel of fortune.
Can't say the words.
I like to solve the puzzles.
That's an example of an algorithm.
Oh,
we're sorry,
Bill.
Oh God.
You have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific to subscribe and receive that month's
crate.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] and enter my code.
Bird is save $3 off on any new subscription today.
Oh look who's back,
everybody.
No coups back.
It's old zip.
Hey Dylan.
How harmony there are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Now you don't post your job in one place isn't enough to find quality
candidates.
White Gump.
I love of this copy just slaps you in the face.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on all the top job sites and now you can find
candidates in any city or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified candidates roll in to zip.
Okay?
It is easy to use interface.
What do they do this with other people?
Okay.
You know what I mean?
Like if you're missing something,
if a dog's missing,
why won't you just post it?
There's gotta be a zip recruiter for that,
right?
Okay.
Try to get felons or something.
Just saying you could.
You could branch this out.
No juggling emails or calls to your office quickly screen candidates.
Rate them and hire the right person fast.
Look at the gams on her.
Yeah,
hired lady ladies,
please send a head to toe photos.
Find out today why sip has been used by fortune 100 companies and thousands of
small and medium size businesses.
And right now my listeners can post jobs on Ziprecruiter for free,
for free by going to ziprecruiter.com/spur that ziprecruiter.com/pat one more
time.
Hi.
Time to try it for free.
Go to old shit.
Yeah.
Slash burner.
All right.
Last one.
Legal Zoom.
Come on in.
Zoom,
zoom,
or zoom.
You remember that's where Ghana,
Zuma,
zoom.
I kinda Gama give it a try.
It's a little bit,
we're going to show you just why we're going to teach you to fly.
Hi.
Come on.
Zoom,
zoom,
legal,
zoom.
A five things owners can count on from legal zoom.
Never would reliability.
More than a million people have already trusted legal zoom to help start their
business.
Incorporations LLCs,
nonprofits,
DBH and more use legal zoom to get started the right way.
Number two,
experience.
You can count on legal zoom for all the details.
I've got it,
honey.
They've been helping all types of business owners for over 15 years.
Number three,
helpful support.
I had taught you.
I hate when people list shit.
I get it.
You're great.
Can we just get to the selling point here?
Helpful help,
full support.
They have the right people standing by ready for your questions,
all basically United States,
you know,
that's Kinda,
that's filler right there as opposed to what non-helpful people in other
countries.
Well yeah,
that's kind of most most companies now,
aren't they?
Yeah.
Hello,
my name is Dave number for legal advice.
Legal Zoom isn't a law firm,
but they have a network of independent attorneys.
They can reverse it.
They can review supplier contracts,
help with your employment laws and advise you on many of the hurdles that pop up
when you're running a business.
And finally,
number five,
no surprises,
legals.
No,
it's kind of sad.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency with upfront pricing,
customer views,
and a satisfaction guarantee.
And they will never celebrate your birthday without letting you know.
First check out legal zoom today.
See no surprises,
nothing new.
Checkout legal zoom today is see how they can make your life better for you and
your business.
And don't forget to enter Berbee you are a checkout to save even more
legalzoom.com.
All right,
well that's it.
Yeah.
What did you think about Sidney Crosby getting another concussion?
You know,
and then the penguins still.
I hope he's okay.
Yeah,
still some outcome is still being up three games or three games to one.
He had three games to one.
Unbelievable.
I feel bad for Josh.
Adam Meyers.
He's really gone through it right now as wizards it down o two to the Bruins and
is capital's down three games to one.
Oh,
he'll be all right.
Yeah,
I know.
It'll be a real pull through.
All right,
that's the podcast.
Thank you everybody for listening and I'm happy.
Anniversary.
Happy Anniversary.
Why are we doing that?
Cause it's your
year anniversary.
I thought you were mocking the end of our TV relationship.
Podcast.
Anniversary.
What?
You just do?
You just go podcast at versa.
You just I I don't,
I don't know why I still can't hold the microphone in my hand.
Well you know what,
Nia,
here's to another 10 years.
You not speaking into the mic.
I think you're going to be doing the podcast 10 years from now.
Absolutely.
I will only be doing the podcast.
I won't be acting anymore.
I won't be touring.
I won't be watching TV and not with me.
I would just be sitting in the room
doing that stuff,
you know?
No,
I'll be hanging out with this little,
this little,
there's a little dumpling Cutie Pie,
Huh?
Yeah.
What's up buddy?
Oh,
I get a smile.
You want to contemplate if moment.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
I'm a,
I have to do my official sign off here and I can't do it in front of the kid
even though I dropped the f bomb up a couple of times.
No idea.
Give me your microphone that you don't talk into
and uh,
I dunno.
Why don't you go watch something and erase it?
I think I will.
You know,
I think the Great Michael Jackson put it best when he said be that,
beat it o open up your mouth and feed it
by lady closed the door.
Wow.
All right.
That's the podcast.
Everybody have a great weekend and I'll,
I'll the,
I don't know.
I won't check in on Y'all.
Talk to you on Monday.
All right.
That said,
while we are waiting,
do you know what?
We're actually going to add a little bit of music and then some of the greatest
hits of,
um,
of a podcast gone by in the last 10 years.
Oh,
by the way,
remember when I told you to check out that band,
the night game,
Emma?
That ball rumor has it,
rumor has it that they're going to be opening for John Mayer.
John Mayer has got a big tour,
um,
going through the United States of America.
There's one stop in Toronto.
The rest of them all.
Uh,
I imagine he'll go around the globe with that cause it does say world tours.
So this is probably the first leg of it.
And he's got two bands opening up.
I forget the name of the other band,
but,
uh,
I believe,
the night game.
I don't know if that's official hope.
It's official,
open on fucking anything up for anybody,
but I,
that was a band I told you guys to check out.
[inaudible] the guy take drum lessons from,
um,
is in that band with a bunch of other amazing studio musicians,
songwriters.
They sound amazing.
So if you do catch John Mayer this summer,
don't show up late.
Don't hang in the parking lot,
shotgun beers or whatever the hell you kids do nowadays.
Taking your Molly smoking your math,
right.
Whatever the hell it is you kids do nowadays,
make sure you get in in time to,
um,
to check out the night game.
And I'm sure the other band is just as good because it doesn't seem like May,
it brings any cupcakes out on the road.
Do you know what I mean?
Like,
you know,
sometimes comedians will do that.
They'll take somebody on the road that isn't as funny,
you know what I mean?
So they don't bring too much heat,
you know?
But the really funny guys,
they don't do that shit.
All right?
But not me.
I bring cupcakes out on the road.
Like Joe de Rosa,
the original cupcake.
He's heat Joe to Rosa is the cupcakes cupcake
of standup comedy.
I miss that guy,
man.
I got to have him back on the podcast at some point.
All right.
Enjoy the music and the,
uh,
the greatest hits.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's spill bar and this is the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
May 4th,
2009 and I think this is the 15th time I've tried to do this podcast.
As you can tell,
my voice is a little bit tired.
I was just working Caroline's in New York City and I did a six shows and I think
I overdid it a little bit even though I was drinking tea.
You know,
start doing that.
Drinking tea with a little bit of honey in it for my shows.
Doing a little fucking vocal,
warm up,
you know?
I mean,
you know,
so I can save my instrument.
I know.
Let's the gays fucking thing ever,
isn't it?
I don't give a fuck.
I have to do it or I'll say end up sounding like this when I,
when I,
when,
when I don't do it,
you know,
I don't know.
It was a weird week in New York.
I didn't do anything.
I just,
I,
I was holed up in my hotel like fucking Howard Hughes.
That's what I do.
Like the further east I go,
the more fucked up it is for me to get up in the morning to do a radio obviously
because if I have to get into the radio station at 7:00 AM east coast time,
that's 4:00 AM my time.
And uh,
that's how I ended up getting sick,
burning at a bolt then.
So I started taking these vitamin C pills because they were freaking everybody
out about the fucking swine flu,
which once again turned out to be nothing.
How many flus in a row are they going to scare the shit out of,
out of us about,
you know,
and you notice every flu.
It's like,
like how did it come about?
It's always somebody had sex with an animal,
somebody,
another country had
sex with an animal,
which is so like nobody is fucking animals in this country.
You know,
I think the CIA puts the shit out that just doing some experiments they need to
thin the fucking heard.
So what they do is they just put the shit out and then they just blame
foreigners and then they add beastiality into it.
So then it just makes sense to Joe lunchbox.
You know,
you can just see him sitting around the fucking canteen truck,
the Roach coach,
whatever you call it,
in your neck of the woods.
And I door the fucking swine flu,
you know.
Well,
we tell,
what's his life?
Who does some guy down in Mexico?
Dude,
he fucking,
he fucked the peg.
He fought a fucking pig.
You know,
we've got plenty of pigs in this country.
You don't see anybody fucking dump those fucking people in Mexico.
Fucking pigs,
dogs just like aids,
those fucking some guy in Africa,
you know,
he fox a monkey and he jerks off the stewardess.
And next thing you know,
I got to wear condom.
It's fucking bullshit deal.
We should close the fucking board is,
um,
notice that was all done in a pseudo Boston accent.
And because that's where I heard most of those conversations as I was growing up
when I worked in a warehouse and I got to met some of the Times I was the guy
saying them as I went out and I got a sausage king for breakfast for my 10:30 AM
break.
Remember that Shit.
You worked in the warehouse and you're just sitting there and it's on Monday and
the days just fly in.
Monday's didn't crawl.
Tuesday's crawled Monday.
He was so fucking bleary eyed from your weekend that the day in some weird way
kind of went by quickly,
you know,
plus you know he kind of excited to get back to work.
Whatever girl there you kinda got a crush on.
You're trying to figure out how to fuck her.
You haven't seen her in a couple of days.
So you've got that level of excitement,
you know he got all that going on.
Maybe a big year team when the big game the day before,
even if they didn't,
you got something to talk about.
Some Monday goes by quick,
but then Tuesday,
Tuesday is when it hits you.
Fuck,
I work here.
I hate this.
This is going to be the same shit all over again.
What the fuck am I doing with my life?
And then itches,
drags ass.
I don't know about you guys,
but back when I had a real job before I,
I just did this bullshit.
Um,
I can't even begin to tell you how fucking long Tuesdays seemed,
it was almost like the,
like the clock,
it was like they,
they're,
they got phony clock on the wall and every minute was actually two minutes,
you know,
I'm telling you it went by slow people.
Why did I need to give that last example?
I don't know what,
but all I know is why I lost a look at the clock like 85 times before 10 15 when
the roach coach would come in and it would blow his horn that,
you know,
but that,
that,
that but tech a dad there,
it didn't do that.
It was something else.
I can't remember,
but it was one of those fucking fancy horns and everybody would just,
a member was losing his shit was like the adult version of when the ice cream
truck came down the street.
Remember that old Eddie Murphy bit,
the ice cream man is coming.
Same Shit,
but for adults.
And then I would literally go out there and I would either get a slice of pizza
off of this truck.
For those of you who always has had a white collar job,
you never,
you know those,
those canteen trucks,
right?
The silver,
it looks like a pickup truck in the front,
the back.
It's all silver and they lift up the side and has all kinds of fucking,
uh,
that's where the fucking swine flu comes from.
God Damn it.
Probably those fucking trucks.
But anyways,
then I would go out there and I would literally get like a slice of pizza like
this and I don't know who made it,
you know what I mean?
Where,
where was it made you get that?
Or I get like a sausage king at 10 30 in the morning,
10 15 in the morning.
And I would just eat that thing after booze and all weekend,
probably downing every bit of 30 fucking beers.
All right?
Probably getting six hours sleep.
If I was lucky,
I had season tickets to the patriots.
I abused my body on that day and then I would finish it off everyday.
Just eaten a fucking sausage king or a slice of pizza.
Just something horrific.
And because I was young,
I had a washboard middle.
I mean,
granted I was working out,
but I'm at the age now.
I,
I would,
I'd have to have,
be on a treadmill the entire fucking day.
That's just cruel.
So if you in your twenties,
enjoy it,
enjoy it and develop some good fucking eating habits because,
uh,
those days don't last right?
Admitted old people don't.
You walk into Mcdonald's sometimes and you're feeling all fucking guilty and you
just see some Douche bags,
not even douche bags.
You just mad because they're young and they're over there laughing,
having a great time.
Everybody's fucking in shape.
Chowing down,
you know,
to make yourself feel better.
You looking over there go,
there's four people over there.
You know what?
Statistically speaking,
one of them's going to drop a heart attack and I'm still living,
so fuck it.
It's like I started my life at this age.
I'm doing all right.
Right?
Yeah.
Let me get the number three with a root beer.
I'm sorry sir.
We don't have root beer is sprayed.
Okay.
Is sprite even remotely like a root beer?
Huh?
You did see count.
Why wouldn't you say coke least?
They're both Brown.
All right,
sorry.
Um,
anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
I do one of these every single week out of the goodness of my heart.
All the horrific things I do all week long.
I wash away all of them every Monday by doing this podcast for my listeners.
That's what I do.
That's why I do it.
This is how I repent,
considering I don't go to church anymore.
You know,
I haven't been to confession.
Confession.
How fucked up was that?
You go in there and your rat yourself out to some other fucking Douche bag and
he's acting like he's acting like,
oh,
you got,
you got to come to me.
And then I'm going to tell God like God didn't
watch everything that I just did.
You know,
I could,
I could do that shit in my bedroom.
You know what I mean?
That's like a,
that's like when you got old technology,
you know what I mean?
Like me,
I just bought an iPod not knowing that phones are basically iPods now.
Yeah.
It just stupid.
It's an extra fucking,
I,
that's a terrible example.
What am I trying to think of?
What am I,
it's like they got what?
They've got wireless mikes now.
For some reason I got a cord on this one.
It could be walking all around my apartment making me,
making myself a sandwich and I'm not,
that's another bad example.
Cheeses.
I'm going to fucking hold there.
You know what I'm saying?
I haven't been to confession in a long time and,
and uh,
I dunno.
I would actually like to start going to church again.
What do you think about that?
Does anybody got any good suggestions out there?
We got a church where it's not the Catholic church.
It's not a church where the person you're in church with started the religion
and it's somehow become a Christ like figure and is trying to brainwash you that
it's okay for him to start having sex with your children.
I don't join a cult.
Okay.
Somewhere between a cult in an organized religion and I don't want any fucking
Mr.
Good vibe shit.
Either.
God.
Well,
why don't I start a church and we go,
I know that's right because I'm not qualified.
I don't know what.
You know what it is?
I like to discipline a church.
Oh,
speaking of that,
you know what dudes I that he say dude's what are kind of assholes still says it
.
You know what dudes,
let me lay this one on you.
I did bought the Bob and Tom Show.
I've been on the road for two weeks.
By the way.
This is basically what happened.
I was working in Columbus,
Ohio,
and then I was going on to work a Caroline's in New York City.
So I had back to back weeks on the road and after that I can tell you what's
underrated.
You know what's underrated?
Sleeping and your own fucking bed is underrated.
Having access to your entire wardrobe is underrated.
Being able to rub one out and not have to put a please don't clean the room now
sign on your door.
That's also,
that's also overrated.
Remembering what the fuck you were talking about.
That's overrated.
Hey,
does anybody have like a,
a help your memory like brain game that I can start playing?
Cause I'm starting to really believe that your brain is a muscle because I am
really losing my train of thought at a disturbing amount every single day now.
And I was just reading this story about,
uh,
you know that [inaudible] asked her lady who passed away in New York,
the aster family Astor place and all that type of shit.
She,
I guess she got Alzheimer's and it sounded like a fucking horrific way to go.
So I started thinking like,
well what if I start playing Pictionary?
What if I go to toys r us and I buy that game that's supposed to help kids
memories,
you know,
we got the cards,
and you turn one over,
it's an owl and you try to find the other aisle and then you try it and it's an
hour and then it's a basset hound and you're like,
fuck,
you know,
and then your parents go,
I knew you weren't going to amount to shit.
Right.
I remember that game.
Isn't there?
Is there an adult version of that than anybody can recommend?
Because seriously,
I really don't want to go out like that.
Is anybody stay staying up on that whole aster family fucking thing where the
guy evidently was the son as the,
as the,
uh,
the older aster lady went into her senile years.
He just started,
you know,
rewriting or will.
So he get all the cash and that's a weird fucking family.
The Astors,
it's like the whole,
that lady,
the lady who just died a couple years ago,
she gave away like $200 million to charity.
But if you look at how they got their shit,
they was slumlords like a century worth of people died of tuberculosis in their
fucking damp,
dark fucking walk in closet apartments that they had.
And then after a while they felt guilty.
So they started giving it away.
But you know what?
I'm on to your game.
They,
to tell you my theory about statues,
unless you're like an artist,
an entertainer,
a sports person or whatever,
you know,
if this has statue of you,
unless you're,
you're one of those kinds of people,
you did something fucked up,
you know?
Does that make any sense to you?
Like Stevie Ray Vaughn got a statue,
right?
What did he do?
He made albums.
He played guitar.
I'm sure you heard some people around him at some point,
you know,
swung his guitar around the strap broke and he fucking smash some chicken.
The teeth.
Maybe that happened,
you know,
but I'm just saying generally speaking,
he didn't hurt anybody.
But then you'll get these other guys,
you're like,
who the fuck is that guy?
Anytime I'll get this,
here's a,
here's a fun exercise.
Next time you walk by a statue,
when you're looking at him like,
who the fuck is that guy?
Go on the internet and just Google whatever his name is and then write a robber
baron after it or some sort of just right corrupt and Google it and watch all
the fucking articles you find granted.
You know you're not really you,
you know,
I never really googled that.
You know the same name and great guy.
I never do that either because I just get a thought in my head.
That's what a lot of people do when they go on the Internet.
You have a thought in your head what you fucking think somebody is or what the
fuck's going on and then you just Google shit in the way you Google it.
It's so everyone will support you.
You know?
It's like if you think someone's an asshole,
you're like,
you know Brian Jones do fish.
And then you Google and then all these artists don't come up and then you go,
there you go.
Look at all the articles.
Right.
See He is a Douche.
You know he's supposed to just Google.
The guy's name and then then peace through them.
I never do that.
I'm actually yelling at myself right now.
You guys want to hear a story?
Um,
Oh,
before I get into that,
I gotta I gotta I gotta rectify something I said last week,
you know,
I was talking about how Pontiac went out of business and I was saying the Trans
am was like their best car.
And I was like,
what else did they have after that?
It goes to the sunburn.
Then the Pontiac t 1000,
there's a major drop off.
I,
uh,
I stand corrected.
Later on that day I was laying in bed and I actually sat up,
right?
And I was like,
how the fuck did I forget the Pontiac Gto?
You know,
the Bonneville,
they had a lot of good cars.
It's not the Aztec.
I'm looking right now,
the top 10
Pontiac's of all time.
And they actually put the Pontiac Aztec.
If that wasn't the ugliest fucking vehicle other than the Chevy Lumina,
remember that thing?
Chevy fucking Illumina.
All right,
so here's something for you guys.
You want to,
you want to look,
I'm really into cars and that type of shit.
If you want to see one of the most fucked up looking vehicles of all time,
Google this,
I'm not even asking you.
I'm telling you Google this,
the a GMC future liner.
All right?
And however you spell it,
you're going to be able to find it.
Um,
this was something that they made in like the 1940s.
They,
this thing called the parade of progress is a great youtube video.
That's something else.
You can Google the parade of progress.
And they had these,
I can't even explain what they are.
It'd be like picture of a toaster eight a Winnebago.
That's what this fucking thing looks like.
Are you looking it up right now?
Yet your desk,
you sit there,
your cubicle pretending like you're doing your real work.
You got to look this thing up.
I apologize to people on planes right now or if you're on a treadmill,
but you gotta look this fucking thing up.
I want to,
I never even heard of these things.
And I was watching one of those auto shows,
you know,
all those rich cops go out and they spent $2 million in a Mustang.
So now I can't buy one.
Well this,
uh,
they actually more than a couple hundred thousand,
but this thing actually went for like a million dollars,
maybe even more.
Um,
it actually to look at it from the side,
it looks like it has four wheels,
but each wheel is doubled.
You know,
like those duly pickups.
So it actually has eight wheels.
And like I said,
it literally looks like a,
the jolly green giant had a toaster with wheels on it.
This is what the fuck that thing would look like.
But um,
I don't think,
I think 99% of of Americans have never seen this thing.
And if you ever had one of those and just drove it down the fucking street,
a bunch of people would look at you and isn't that,
isn't that what we're all asking for?
Everyone's going to look in your direction and be like,
wow,
who's that guy?
Is he a rebel?
Um,
all right.
I gotta read this fucked up email before.
This isn't even the podcast.
This is just me bullshitting around here.
Let me get into his,
a story somebody said to me,
which brings up an interesting debate here.
Uh,
I says,
hey bill,
my name is so and so.
I'm just writing to let you know you're my favorite comedian.
I really can relate to everything you say.
Not sure if that's good or bad.
Ello fucking l m I bought tickets to see you on Friday at Caroline's in New
York.
I spent over $200 on tickets about a month before so that me and my friends
could go and have a grand old time.
Well,
Lo and behold,
of course the shit only happens to me.
We get on the train two hours before you go on,
so we can get there plenty of time and watch the show.
But Lo and behold,
what happens?
Some fucking lady decided that she was going to end her life and get hit by the
train in front of mine.
I know it's a sad thing and I should feel bad,
but fuck that.
I was like,
really,
lady,
are you serious of all the fucking trains?
It had to be the one that I was on that got delayed two hours.
I'm like,
fuck,
if you want to kill yourself because you know,
cause you're miserable with your life,
go shoot yourself a jump off a bridge.
But don't make us all suffer.
So anyways,
long story short,
I only got to see the last 30 minutes you show,
which was great,
but I was disappointed that we couldn't see the whole thing.
I'm not sure when you'll be in New York again.
I'm sure your website,
we'll post a,
we'll post the date whenever it will be.
While you're probably wondering why the fuck I'm writing you,
while I have to vent to someone that's on my level of understanding,
understanding people's
Suck Jesus Christ.
While I'm sorry.
Uh,
sorry to hear that.
You know,
you should've,
you should've told me that story.
You know,
I would have fucking,
I would have tossed you a DVD at the end,
would have given you something for your Theora,
your troubles,
um,
yet you bring up a good point.
You know,
if you're going to kill yourself,
it's bad enough.
You're going to make everyone around you suffer.
Buddy.
I'm me.
Complete strangers.
Suffer the lay there at night.
Have Fun
on a fucking let it go.
Jesus Christ.
I could tell you right now,
uh,
there is no way to do a thorough clean up after somebody jumps in front of a
fucking train.
There's no fucking way you're getting every piece.
You know what I mean?
There's no way.
If you don't believe me,
why don't you go get a flank steak and stick and mad in it and light it off in
your kitchen,
clean it up the best of your ability and I guarantee you six months from now
you're going to be fine and Shit in the curtains.
You know,
there's just,
uh,
and yeah,
for those of you who didn't wonder,
this is a very educational podcasts.
That's,
that's what like jumping in front of a train is,
that's exactly what it's like lighting off an MIT in a flank.
Steak in a kitchen.
All right,
so right now,
even if you press stop and you never listen to the rest of this,
you actually fucking learned something.
All right,
so here we go.
This is the podcast.
This is what the fuck I do.
I do it every single Monday.
People send me questions and a information.
We have a list of stuff that's overrated and underrated.
Uh,
people send me stories about revenge and all that type of shit.
Have I really been talking for fucking 20 minutes?
Is that true?
Did I fuck up again?
You know what?
There's no way for me to know as shit.
I have to hit stop.
Fuck,
fuck.
All right,
so I fucked up.
You know,
I thought I,
uh,
Jeez.
I can't even tell you what the fuck I thought.
I can't even explain it.
I thought,
I thought it was only three minutes into the podcast.
I looked down and sit in 19 minutes and I thought I fucked up.
I thought I started the podcast at the end of another fucked up podcasts and
turned out I didn't.
So there's just going to be two tracks this week,
which a lot of UX she should probably enjoy on some level because a number of
you give me shit about how big my files are moved.
The two too long to download mean well,
why don't you upload,
uh,
upload,
upgrade your fucking technology and what do you want from me?
I don't know how to do this shit.
Stop giving me shit.
All right.
Fucking people.
Every week.
People seem to like last week when I was all hung over,
so a lot of people said it wasn't my best podcasts of all time,
but there was a couple of people who actually went out of their way to tell me
that they thought that it sucked,
you know,
don't do anymore hung over podcast.
I can add that.
That one kind of thought women really didn't like it.
That I say something really mean about women because the only ones who didn't
like it were women.
You know,
I don't know if you have drunk boyfriends,
you know,
or spouses.
He was such a swell guy.
And then after we got married,
everything was going,
he was going great.
And then one day I work,
he hurt his back and that he started taking pain pills.
And then you had an episode of intervention,
you know.
So is that what it reminded you of?
I wasn't trying to piss anyone off.
All right.
Um,
so anyways,
having survived the epidemic in New York City,
the swine flu epidemic,
I was so sick of them using the words epidemic and pandemic,
you know,
I was like,
what the fuck is the difference?
So basically an epidemic is when you,
I guess it's some sort of whatever,
it's some sort of disease or some shit,
but it's confined.
It's confined to one country I guess.
And a pandemic is global,
you know,
and if it's just in an area,
in a country that's a breakout,
but the definition of an epidemic every evidently what makes something an
epidemic according to Wikipedia,
I'm saving you guys time.
You don't have to look it up and read it.
Cause that's where I get it from an epidemic is basically,
uh,
it basically says defining an epidemic can be subjective.
Um,
depending in part on what is expected and epidemic may be rustic,
restricted to one local locale and outbreak like I just said,
a more general and epidemic or even global pandemic.
Um,
because it is based on what is expected or thought normal.
A few cases of a very rare disease,
like rabies may be classified as an epidemic,
while many cases of the common common diseases like the common cold would not,
you know what I mean?
So basically if you know,
five people had rabies out here in la,
that would be considered an epidemic
because that's five more than they expected.
Uh,
but if everybody had the fucking ass flu,
you know,
they'd be like,
well,
you know,
we told them to wear condoms.
Um,
all right,
let's get to the a overrated underrated here for this week.
Uh,
overrated.
This guy sends in,
he said,
a red sox sweeping the Yankees in April.
I thought that that was hilarious because not only is that true,
it is just April,
but what I really found funny is that if the Yankee swept the red sox,
that dude would not think that it was overrated.
He would be like,
you see,
we fucking all you guys fucking Boston goes fucking shock.
Everything closes by one's fucking city.
So fucking lame.
Can't even get a fucking slash um,
I don't think the red sox sweeping the Yankees and April is overrated.
You know,
you know,
I think it's overrated spending $420 million on three fucking guys.
What do think about that?
That's fucking overrated.
Spending $200 million a year to not win the world series is overrated.
I don't understand.
Why don't they Yankees trust their farm system?
Oh,
I know why they don't trust them because all their farm system has ever given
them is Lou Gehrig.
Joe Dimaggio,
Mickey Mantle,
Derek Jeter,
Andy Pettitte,
Bernie Williams,
Jorge Posada.
Why the fuck would you,
why would you wait around to build a team when you can go out and spend hundreds
of millions of dollars on shitheads?
There,
can you fuck them?
They're not going to win it again this year.
Fucking unbelievable.
I was sitting there going to foreign to $20 million and three guys.
There's no fucking way,
you know,
and to share.
It was on the angels last year.
I mean,
that guy,
he looked like a beast.
I don't know.
I actually went to Yankee stadium on a Sunday,
new Yankee stadium,
and I gotta admit I really had a lot of mixed emotions.
Uh,
as I,
as I got out there,
I got off and I looked at old Yankee stadium.
I'm like,
that's Yankee stadium.
You know,
I don't know.
I'm a sentimental jackass.
I'm into the history,
you know,
I loved going into that place.
That fucking place was awesome.
You know,
even though so many horrific things happen to the red sox there,
I mean,
Jesus,
if you have any sort of a sports fan,
he got it.
You got to respect that.
That's the,
uh,
that's the number one stadium and all four sports,
without a doubt.
26 fucking championships.
Not even those fucking sissies up in Montreal can say that,
you know,
hey,
what do you think?
Did I ask you guys this question?
What do you think's the most overrated team with like,
like as far as the has like the most amount of championships.
I was talking to this with a,
with a guy the other day.
Like do you ever notice like in any sort of league there's always a,
there's always one team in the,
in the inception of a league that always goes on a run in the beginning and they
go on such a run that,
you know,
basically for the most part it's going to take another century to catch up with
them if you even can,
you know?
Do you know what I'm saying?
Like look at the South Texas Celtics went on that run in the 60s it's like,
come on man,
do you,
you see what people look like?
They,
they,
they barely will.
Like the league just started,
you know what I mean?
I mean,
you look at that shit the way they play.
Like,
Gee,
I think I could have fucking made the final cut,
you know?
And then he got the Yankees,
they,
they one way back,
a whole bunch back in the three stooges era.
But,
uh,
I really don't disrespect the baseball one.
What's once they let black people and Latinos in and that type of shit,
the Yankees still fucking dominated.
But,
uh,
I,
I think I might have to go with the Canadians just for the simple fact that
there were only six teams,
you know what I mean?
So I think it's kind of easy,
much easier to go on a run and hockey than it was in basketball or even baseball
cause bay.
I think baseball had like,
uh,
how many teams or they have,
I,
Jesus,
I probably should have looked this up.
I used to know this shit.
I think they had about fit 14,
16 and I was like,
yeah,
maybe 12 teams.
Um,
but here's another thing too,
back in the day when,
when you went to the world and if you won the division that was winning the
pennant,
you know,
and then you just immediately went to the world series.
There wasn't fucking around of playoffs before the world series for a while
until they got past a certain amount of teams and uh,
you know,
when to stay on the copy had to win eight games.
That's a whole nother fucking deal.
You know what I mean?
Like nowadays,
like all these,
all these teams,
there's like 30 teams in every single fucking league now.
So now you got a one in 30 chance as opposed to back in the day,
look in hockey,
you had a one in six chance of winning the cup and it's something else.
I didn't notice either.
The amount that the Toronto may believe hung with the Canadians right up til
1967 they were like neck and neck.
They will like 15 Stanley cups.
Verse 13
fucking Toronto was right there,
man.
And then they just,
they just shit the bed my whole life.
Then I was born,
I think I'm cursing the Toronto Maple leafs.
Um,
put our branches.
I'm,
you know what,
before the [inaudible] fans get pissed,
I'm just breaking your balls because I know you guys.
You won like what'd you went?
Seven cups in the 70s.
Is that what you did?
I think you did.
And that was with the expansion 12th.
But even that was bullshit.
Cause then they took the expansion six and they just put them in their own
fucking division.
So then all you had to do was just a,
when the other division and then you went up against like the fucking Saint
Louis Blues like we did.
I like the north star is Assam Shit.
All right.
That last three minutes.
Where was for the fucking sports nerds?
All right,
let me move on here.
Oh,
I didn't say so.
I wanted to new Yankee Stadium and I got to admit like,
I don't know man.
I,
I w I got to,
it was weird because you will,
looking at the Yankees,
I felt like I was at legends field.
You know,
I was like,
those are the New York Yankees.
But this is not their house.
I don't feel,
I don't feel the history,
you know.
Um,
and I also got admit,
it kind of looked like every other fucking stadium except it had that cool
facade.
The facade is the shit outside of the stadium is the ship.
And inside it just Kinda was like fucking voice cracks inside,
inside the stadium.
It just kind of looked like a,
I dunno,
I think I might like pac bell a little better.
I'll have to go again.
You know what's so amazing?
Shit has to happen there for that's,
that's the same,
all of those fucking things.
I can just go to Shea stadium and even after the red sox won it,
I would still look at that spot where the boat,
where the ball went through Buckner's legs.
Except after we won it,
then it would,
I then I also saw the humor in it,
but until then,
until that point,
uh,
I didn't.
All right.
Moving on here.
The other thing that people say is a overrated,
uh,
the peoples,
peoples,
Kentucky Derby Pics.
I hate all these people who basically only watched three horse races a year and
they only watch three horse races a year.
Yet they,
they give me,
they come up to me and they give you a g,
you know,
something that half,
this isn't fucking me.
You know what?
I was actually going to blame the guy fucking route there,
but I can't,
you know,
that's actually how I've read it.
All right,
let me,
let me start over again.
People's Kentucky Derby Pics.
I hated how all these people who basically only watched three races a year yet
yet.
No,
you did fuck up yet.
They give you their derby picks and they say shit like it's going to be a sloppy
track today.
This horse thrives on a sloppy track.
Does he?
You know what?
That was such a great fucking point and I really butchered that.
Yeah,
I know.
Everybody starts acting like they're fucking Jack Klugman.
You know,
with a rolled up program,
nobody gives a fuck about horse racing.
You know,
back in the day,
horse racing and boxing used to be the number one sports.
Granted there was no football,
baseball and hockey,
basketball,
none of that shit was around then.
One was around and took a while for it to take over.
This is just all going to be sports this week.
Uh,
pay per view.
Boxing matches are overrated.
They're never worth the money.
It's just all about the marketing.
I'm glad I didn't spend $50 on the hat and park.
Was it parky of Packeo fight because a,
it was on youtube for free about two hours later.
Although I will buy a PA EEO or Packeo have you say his name May.
Whether if that happens.
Well that's good to know,
sir.
I'm underrated.
Uh,
how gay those frilly boxing trunks,
some fighters where I think it's,
I think it's,
see this is the shit.
I can't read it cause it's too fucking small and going on.
I'm getting old here.
I think it's health hysterical.
When some fighters come out wearing some something Liberace would wear and then
they just get the shit beat out of them.
This guy really wrote some funny shit.
I'm just butchering it.
I guess I could never be a fucking newscaster.
Let me try that again.
Okay.
Underrated.
How gay those frilly boxing trunks.
Some fighters were C,
that's a fragment.
That's what trips me up.
She'd say how gay some of those frilly boxing trunks are that some of the
fighters were.
I think it's hysterical when when a fighter comes out wearing something that
only Liberace would wear and then he goes on to get the shit kicked out of them.
Say they,
that's what I'll do.
I'll get the gist of it.
I'll just paraphrase.
Underrated a massages with happy endings for 100 bucks.
You get a 60 minute massage that ends with an agent and Asian chick beating you
off and the top it off at the end for no extra charge.
She'll give you a table shower,
which is basically a bath.
It's how God must get a hand job.
Dude,
you write really funny shit.
I mean,
I'm not telling you to go out there and you might,
you might get a future.
This son,
there's Sonny boy.
Hey,
getting back to the,
uh,
the,
the swine flu shit.
There was a bunch of people walking around New York with those mass on those
little surgical masks.
How fucking hilarious is that?
It's an airborne virus.
I don't understand the thought process key.
You're breathing through the mass.
What is it?
What is,
well,
actually you can get through.
We're not to pig virus.
You oxygen is just a wee bit smaller than the pig virus.
Pick various,
just hits the front of the mask and then that's it.
I was on my flight today,
flying out here from New York City.
And,
uh,
this is sort of weird and I want to know from my,
my Asian constituents,
whatever the fucking word is.
Um,
there was about six people on the plane who were all wearing those surgical
masks.
Like they were going to amputate somebody's leg during the civil war or doing a
fucking guest star on Mash.
They were wearing,
and they were all Asian.
Only the agents were wearing those.
And what does that from,
was that because they had to live through SARS and,
and they made it by the grace of God.
But there's some for some reason like attributing the,
uh,
the mass to it.
Does anybody know?
Does anybody know out there?
Anybody?
Anybody out there in podcast land?
All right,
I have to do the fucking math here,
um,
to 29 minutes.
Not to go too long.
All right.
By the way,
a bill,
congratulations on the Celtics feeding the bowls,
but I want to know how you feel about Derrick rose.
Just basically bitch slapping Brian Scalabrine in game seven with that nasty ass
block.
Uh,
considering we won the series,
I think I feel pretty fine about it.
I actually did a show that night and I miss game seven.
But,
uh,
you guys are going to be great man.
Do you guys have a great young team?
And uh,
that
Guy Brian Scalabrine,
is that the fucking dude who looks like a Jesus Christ?
I always forget his fucking name.
What is that act as fucking name?
I always think Michael and then that screw on Matthew Modine.
I always think there's an m in it.
You know the guy he was in cop land,
he played the cop that had to disappear.
Uh,
what is his fucking mean?
That's exactly what that fucking dude looks like.
Ah,
Shit.
He would start in that.
That short lived sit-com the war at home actually at mid last at a season.
So that's actually successful these days away.
They cancel the fuck is his name.
I swear to God man.
I'm,
I'm like literally,
I'm losing my mind here
now we have to Google it.
I have to take time out of the fucking podcast.
The,
I have titled One Hand Cause I'm holding my Monday night football fucking
microphone here.
The war at home isn't Sankey Trinity where
Michael Rappaport,
there we go.
That's how he looks like he looks like Michael Rappaport.
I went to that Celtics,
Utah Jazz game out new tower.
Garnette got hurt and then Michael Rappaport Dude,
I watched him have one file in the first half and then he filed out in the third
quarter in the span.
I swear to God a four minutes.
I haven't seen any shit like that since Darryl Dawkins and I swear to God,
that's the end of the sports shit.
All right,
for the rest of you,
here we go.
We're going to move on here.
Uh,
moving onto the next part of the podcast.
Where the fuck am I?
Okay.
Somebody wants my advice.
Dear Bill,
I guess this falls under the,
I need advice column of the podcast.
Uh,
my 30th birthday is four days before you're 41st according to Wikipedia.
And I got to admit that I'm not looking forward to it.
I just feel like I'm getting old and it's sucks our work with this kid who's 23
and a one day a couple of weeks ago,
I caught myself in the middle of his speech about how lucky he is to be 23 and
how as a dude that's the perfect age,
23 years old,
all I,
all I can remember was at that age I had pussy falling out of my pockets and
let's just say things have dried up since then.
I promptly shut the hell up when I realized I was starting to sound like my dad,
but the kid was actually listening to me and asking questions about typical guy
shit.
So basically what I'm asking is what advice would you please offer to me about
relationships in life in general?
You know,
like if I knew what I knew,
what I know now,
kind of shit,
thanks in advance.
All right,
so obviously do,
do your relationships aren't working out.
So you've made the,
uh,
the brilliant decision to ask someone who's never made a relationship work.
Actually,
my relationship now is working,
right?
Um,
what are,
what is the advice?
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Where the fuck do I
be selfish.
Here you go.
That's a good one.
I mean,
in your dating,
I'm literally tangled up in a fucking
wires here.
All right?
That's what you gotta do you gotta be selfish and uh,
before you start date,
before you get back out,
just,
just make a list of shit that you want.
You know,
like practical shift.
Don't be like big [inaudible] fucking round as she's got to have nice toes.
Uh,
what else do you know?
What the fuck else is there?
Nice face.
You know,
Josh is nice but not a fucking war.
You know what I'm saying?
Um,
you've got to have some other shit too.
I don't know.
I mean,
I haven't been able to,
uh,
get married yet,
so that seems to be the pinnacle of what makes a healthy relationship for some
fucking reason.
But,
uh,
I did have a buddy of mine and who was a complete fucking maniac and he got
married and I asked him,
uh,
how we went about doing it and he just said he just
dumped all the fucking,
you know,
all those girls you got in your cell phone,
as much as you're saying that dried up,
you know,
you've got all those numbers in your cell phone,
you know those numbers,
those numbers.
You only call at one 30,
two o'clock in the morning.
You know,
those girls,
you got to sever ties with those girls because it's just,
it's too fucking easy.
It's like,
it's like,
it's like junk food.
If you've got it laying around in your house,
you're gonna become a,
you're just going to get,
it's going to eat it.
You open the bag,
eat the whole fucking thing,
and then you're sitting there going,
why the fuck did I do that?
You know?
Then I read a blog up,
I wrote a blog about that.
How whores are like the,
the human equivalent to a fucking bag of Doritos.
Um,
how the fuck is it?
19 minutes again,
what's 19 in 1938 there we go.
Okay,
I got to 12 minutes here.
Um,
yeah,
so just really figured out what the fuck you want.
And this guy,
one of the great things he did was he,
if he found out he found out a girl he was dating,
one of the first questions he asked is if her parents were still together and if
they were still together,
he,
there will be a second date.
And if there,
if they weren't still together,
there wasn't a second date and a,
I know a lot of people would get offended about that shit,
but that's a great way to get a pure bred,
you know,
other shit,
I don't know you,
you just got to make a list of what the fuck you want.
But you really got to stop.
Uh,
you got to stop fucking with the horse and it's a hard thing.
It's definitely a hard thing.
And,
uh,
ah,
Jeez.
I'm just,
I'm a little jet lag here,
dude.
If you ask me something a little more space,
some better when you ask me specific things,
because if you asked me an overall question like that.
All right,
what else can I come on,
Bill?
Think,
uh,
alright.
Everybody's nuts.
Including you.
And uh,
so you got to,
you got to find,
you've got to pick someone that compliments your crazy.
You know what I mean?
You can't and you won't.
You think you want to get somebody who's the same kind of crazy.
So then you guys relate to each other.
But that's,
that's not good because then you're both going bat shit at the same time.
And when that happens,
you,
neither one of you have anybody call to bail
you out of the holding cell.
Um,
you know what I mean?
what else?
Jesus fucking Christ,
uh,
don't date those girls who say they used to be a whore,
but now they're not.
Don't date those girls.
Um,
what else?
I don't fucking know,
Dude.
I'm,
I'm really trying here.
You know what to write.
Write me back next week.
Ask me something more specific.
I'm just really go,
I'm going blank here.
I'm really,
I'm really choking on this one.
I usually have a ton of shit to say.
Why is my fucking software updates are available for your computer?
Do you want to install them now?
I'm doing a fucking podcast.
Not now.
Uh,
Shit.
Well you know what,
if anybody else out there has some fucking advice to give him,
obviously I got,
I got nothing.
I only have advice about how to get out of relationships like that dude,
that one time he was asking me and you want the biggest thing,
I actually had to email him back,
I forgot to tell him was when he was getting away from that just to do a recap.
He was with this girl,
she had a couple of kids with another guy and he was kind of in the relationship
with her and he was semi passed out when he was drunk and when,
when he walked up she was fucking flirting with,
with his best friend.
So he's trying to get out of the relationship and I told him basically he knew
what he needed to do,
but I forgot the number one thing that I,
uh,
I forgot to tell him was under no circumstances should he ever fuck that girl
again.
Uh,
you've got to watch out for those girls that already have kids by somebody else.
You really got to watch out in general.
You got to watch out during that breakup time.
You really got to watch out because there's a lot of crazy fucking people go
nuts guys.
And women go nuts.
Guys could get physical that he start stocking you.
They go that route.
Women can get crazy and accidentally take themselves off the fucking pill
in some sort of fucked up desperation.
Either they keep it going or was even worse,
some sort of vengeance thing.
They just not thinking clearly and then they get knocked up and next thing you
know,
they're thinking clearly and they don't want the fucking kid either.
And yet you're joined at the hip,
so wear a fucking condom.
That's another thing to wear a fucking condom.
And uh,
yeah,
do that shit.
Wear a condom.
You know,
that's another good thing too.
If you get with a girl and she starts asking you if you've been tested and that
type of shit,
that's a good thing.
You want a Bronx tale?
Like lock the door test hookup with a girl.
All right.
And uh,
when you get ready to do the deed,
don't bring up a condom.
And if she doesn't flinch,
you know,
stand up and just walk out with yard on.
No one has the fucking strength to do that,
but at least for the love of God fucking put one on.
All right.
That's it.
Do that.
That advice really sucked.
I'm telling you,
just asked me something more specific.
I'll try to help you out.
Um,
all right,
let's get to the final thing that I'm going to do this week.
A little jet lag this week
and it's hot as fuck in this room.
For some reason I can't open the goddamn windows because a,
it picks up every sound from the street.
Uh,
last week I actually asked a question about,
uh,
how to change the default on my computer for the size of the font when I type
out my files because I'm really bad at computers and uh,
somebody actually helped me out with it.
Like that day.
It's really simple.
If you're an apple work,
she'd go to edit
a up on the toolbar there.
You Click on edit,
fucking do it right now and click on edit and what do you wait,
what the fuck?
This doesn't make sense.
Go to edit.
No,
you don't click on apple works.
That's what you want to do.
Go on apple works.
Then you click on prevalence premise preferences.
All right,
let me start over again.
You go to apple works,
click on that.
You go into preferences and then you click on general.
And uh,
let's see if I can do this here.
Oh yeah.
And then you'll see your default size is right there.
And then you just click on the fucking heroin.
You could pick one of those sides and then he hit.
Okay.
That's how you doing.
I know that's very basic.
If you guys have some more difficult fucking questions you want to ask them on
this podcast,
I will read them.
And this computer nerds out there that can not wait to fucking help you.
Um,
what else do we got here?
I think I have,
I think I just have a fucking hangover story and then our vengeance thing.
Wow.
I'm really losing momentum here.
I don't know what to do.
Say at the beginning of fucking $6 million man.
You know when that little fucking kite that he's flying,
why don't they ever show that fucking show in reruns?
That's one of the greatest goddamn shows ever.
Do you guys ever see that?
You have any idea how fucking huge it was when the $6 million man fought the $7
million man and he punched his fucking face off his face came off on television
in like 1974.
Do you have any fucking idea?
Think about that.
Pre Internet,
pre cable,
pre any sort of special effect.
You look how bad the graphics were in Star Wars.
This is like three,
four years before that Lee Majors Punch this dude who was the fucking bad guy
and everything.
Oh Man.
Do you remember the one where the $6 million man fight up,
fought in the snow outside that mansion and they had everybody in slow motion
and that black dude jumped like 10 feet in the air was going to kick him.
He's gone
flying through the fucking air.
Then you've got to stand how sheltered I was as a kid.
I didn't even know who Bruce Lee was.
I don't even know what Kung Fu fighting was.
And I didn't realize that TV shows were ripping off,
you know,
uh,
enter the dragon and all that shit that people were flipping out about.
Cause I was just a little kid.
So I saw that shit.
I,
it was the most unbelievable thing ever.
He fought big foot.
He fought a black Bruce Lee and he fought the $7 million man and he punched his
fucking face off
and uh,
tele.
They just don't,
they don't make,
it's impossible to compete now.
There's just,
they've just done too many things.
You know,
it's kind of like when you go to write a movie script and like everything's been
done and they act like all these guys back in the forties and fifties were
brilliant.
It's like fuck you.
There was only like five movies were ever made.
How hard was it to be brilliant back then?
It's like inventing shit in the,
in the 1800 [inaudible] oh look,
it's a coat hanger.
You can hang your coat on it.
Holy Shit.
Let's put his name in the history books.
Everyone can fucking remember this for the rest of the time.
I don't even know what you could invent.
You always great.
It's still inventing a simple shit.
Is that Billy Mays guy you don't let bear did fuck every night.
He just starts sobbing.
Billy Mays.
That dude,
he doesn't even event the shit.
I think he invented like three things and then he's just got a sweatshop or like
smart fucking kids from Thailand and he just comes walking in.
I keep borrowing and myself on the iron.
Come up with some shit.
Then like three weeks later he's on TV.
Are Billy Mays,
are you tired of burn their hair off your forearm or your in your button down
cause your third marriage didn't work out and you still have to date in your 50s
introducing the fucking thing.
You stick in front of the iron that doesn't burn your forearm but still irons,
fucking shirt.
Um,
anyways.
Oh let me get,
let me get back to this thing.
Sorry.
Huh.
See like that.
There you go.
I wanted to stand at Mo gave me some fucking laughs.
Okay.
All right.
Hang over here.
Let me get,
let me get back here.
So here's a hangover.
Last week I did a,
I did a podcast where he had a hangover and ah,
somebody gave me some sort of Ah,
ah Jesus,
can you tell them stolen at the time cause I went to the wrong fucking place.
Advice I give that guy horrible advice.
Um,
all right.
Yeah.
I was kind of fucking hung over the last week,
so I had somebody give me advice on how to cure a hangover and a,
this is what I got.
Here's a grace.
Here's a great hangover tip.
Works for me most of the time.
Eat a greasy breakfast with all the coffee you can fucking stomach the morning
after drinking.
[inaudible]
I recommend waffle house or some other piece of shit diner.
You know what?
Some people,
you know what?
I've always heard the greasy breakfast thing.
People actually had some other ones I had never heard of and I evidently I
didn't fucking,
I didn't save those.
Oh,
well.
Well,
we're going to end the podcast right here.
We're going to end with a revenge story.
All right?
Uh,
all right,
Bill.
Sometimes revenge comes when you least expect it.
I like that this person started their revenge story with this.
That sounds like a great trailer for a,
for a summer blockbuster.
You know,
Tom Hanks,
Meg Ryan,
and some other Douche bag that you don't give a fuck star in the revenge.
Sometimes revenge comes when you least expect it.
All right.
My,
my brother Jamie had always tease me about something since it had happened when
I was about 15,
but I can't tell you what it was because it will ruin the rest of the story.
But I had my day of revenge.
All right.
Fast Forward Tor.
Uh,
fast forward eight years,
I was managing a rock band full time and my brother was about to move out to la
to take a shot at acting.
So we had moved out of his apartment,
was temporary temporarily crashing up the street from my place at a mutual
friend's apartment.
We all lived in these apartments in a small town in South Jersey.
Me and one of the guys from the band,
we're living in an apartment that was connected to a house,
have a family we sort of grew up with.
They had a son,
Charlie,
who was our age but had down's syndrome.
So we still lived at home.
Charlie would always seem to pop into our apartment at the worst times.
Uh,
you know,
in like the middle of parties when we were smoking pot or maybe when I was on
the couch with a girl trying to get laid,
he just had this timing where he would show up at the exactly the wrong time.
On this particular Sunday afternoon,
I called my brother to let them know we had ordered some pizzas and sandwiches
and he could come over and have some,
have some,
if he wanted a,
we'd all been drinking heavily the night before as me and the band were out of
town,
out of town on tour.
My brother got perfectly blunted.
I think he was supposed to try to say,
uh,
the previous night and I knew he'd be,
see,
this is what sucks about this small
fucking font.
Please write in bigger type guys or us.
I got to put my face right up to the goddamn screen.
You guys are making me blind here.
All right.
My brother got fucked up the other night and I knew he'd be on our buddy's couch
just hating life.
But when I called him up,
he was being a bitch and asked if I could actually bring the fucking food over
to her.
You guys understand what's going on here.
They're all hung over his brother order some pizzas and out of the goodness of
his heart,
he calls his brother up the street and the fucking lazy concert.
Can you,
can you bring it over?
So this,
so there's dude,
like a normal person says,
fuck no,
I bought the food.
I'm offering you some if you want it,
just come over.
But he couldn't get off the couch.
I'm Charlie,
the down syndrome kid who must've seen the pizza delivery guy knocked on our
door minutes later.
Uh,
my roommate Tom and I then thought of something fun to do.
Charlie actually really liked my brother.
They were always messing around.
But if you ever,
if you ever hung out with a kid with Down's syndrome,
that usually means he wants to fight or fight you or wrestle.
This is reminding me of something about Mary.
Um,
since my brother was being such a lazy turn and when come over,
we thought it'd be funny to have Charlie delivered the pizza to Jamie since we
knew Charlie,
I guess James,
his brother,
excuse me.
MMM.
Whatever.
I have Charlie delivered to Jamie since we knew Charlie would immediately wants
to wrestle and fuck around with him,
constant consequently would make his hangover much fucking worse.
So anyways,
I'm mutual friends with,
with us.
And he had the key to the apartment where,
where my brother was staying on the couch.
We all walked over to the apartment and,
uh,
down the hall to the Living Room where my brother was on the couch with the back
of the couch towards the door and the TV facing us.
We immediately realized that my brother was watching a nasty,
nasty porno and was beating off Jesus Christ.
I started to say,
Hey,
here's your pizza.
And then I was like,
oh,
no.
But,
uh,
Charlie,
Charlie first pass me there.
My brother's stuck his head up over the back of the couch before he knew it.
Charlie used all of his retard strength to give Jamie the haymaker of a lifetime
to the back of his head.
My brother was dazed and early confused.
He stood up and had on Oli and old half shirt from high school football and
white socks and oh yeah,
he had a raging hard on.
Now Charlie's coming at him go and my brother's looking at us to stop Charlie,
but we're all laughing too hard and none of us were going to go anywhere near
that situation.
Uh,
Charlie.
Okay.
I mean,
would you,
would you break up a fight between a nearly naked guy with a boner and a kid
with down syndrome?
Where would you start?
Um,
Charlie was not quitting and blah,
blah,
and he's put a on his best move was to punch your balls.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
did this really happen?
This sounds fucking crazy.
Um,
he was coming at Jamie with everything he had.
Uh,
my brother was just trying to hold them off till is harder,
hard on subsided and he could gather himself.
Meanwhile,
the TV's still on all loud and some nasty old fat chick was getting banged in
the ass by some black dude.
It was complete mayhem.
It all happens so fast.
Finally,
my brother pushed Charlie away far enough to grab his shorts and put them on.
Charlie was really tired.
It was really fired up because we had given them,
giving them a big glass of Pepsi beforehand and I was not supposed to have
caffeine.
Well that's,
that's a great thing to do.
Uh,
Bubba,
Bubba ball.
Um,
anyways,
my brother would,
okay,
so this is basically the,
this is the thing.
He was talking about how,
what his brother used to tease him off.
He said,
my brother would always used to tease me about the time he caught me beat
beating off when I was 15.
He was like a true older brother,
uh,
two rather brother Dick about it and would bring it up in front of other girls,
family and whoever,
and just kept,
just kept doing it for years after the time that retard beat him up while he was
whacking off,
he never mentioned it again.
Cheers.
Jesus Christ.
Dude did that.
Did that all really happen?
Um,
sorry about saying retard too.
I never say that shit.
He just had written that I tried to say fucking down syndrome as much as I
could.
There you go.
You found a line.
I usually don't say that shit.
Um,
anyway,
so that's the podcast for the weekend.
I was pretty fucking a,
that's pretty fucked up.
You know,
you've got a 19 minute one and you've got a 35 minute once.
What does that make?
That makes foams?
That's like almost 55 fucking minutes.
Um,
I'm going to be at the Improv in Los Angeles,
um,
in May.
I don't know what weekend yet.
I believe it's the weekend of May 20 something.
And uh,
other than that we're going to be filling in some stand updates.
Um,
and that's it.
Thank you guys for listening to the Monday morning podcast.
Please keep the questions coming and coming and I apologize I was a little bit
jet lag.
That's two fucking weeks in a row,
you know,
hung over last week jetlag this week.
But you know,
what the fuck do you want for me?
It's called the Monday morning podcast and I have to do it on this day,
so,
so there you go.
I hope you guys enjoyed it and I'll talk to you next week.
All right.
Do you next week.